welcome to exploring computing
today's video is web page reproduction
the washington post so in this video
we're going to take a look at how to
reproduce a part of the washington post
so what i have here on the left is the
entirety of the washington post
um which you can see it's actually quite
quite long
and then the red section down at the
bottom that's actually the section we're
going to reproduce
sadly they ended up cutting this so
um i reproduced this last uh
last spring and it's it's no longer
there but
hey this is part of a professional web
page even though it's no longer with us
so this is going to provide some
interesting
points particularly on borders
and some subtleties in terms of
making your elements look a little bit
more interesting
that you might not normally think of
and then in addition it's going to just
emphasize as as i've been doing
throughout this idea that you want to
use your cascading style sheet to set up
your presentation
and that particularly with grid based
layout you can
get a lot of flexibility by
putting the presentation information in
the cascading style sheet
and having the semantic information like
what it's a heading
uh you know what are particular sections
uh semantically um you know like uh
in this particular case which section is
the politics section which section is a
world section which section is a
national section
by putting that semantic information in
the html
and then pulling the presentation
information in the cascading style
sheets you get a lot of flexibility
all right one thing that you may notice
here is that there is this
black bar running across the web page
and you can see that
in the super miniaturized version up at
the top and then here i've got a view of
the top of the web page and then i have
a view of the section that i'm
reproducing
that bar there is going to stay there
fixed regardless of which section of the
web page you're using
i'm not going to talk about that today
but we'll see in another lecture exactly
how you can actually set that up
okay and so what we have on the left is
my reproduction of the section
and then on the right we have the actual
web page
and again i'm using the alarm ipsum that
we've seen previously
uh in a number of other lectures so i'm
not using their actual headlines
and i'm not using their actual images
either
those are my images on the left okay so
here's the html
and you can see that basically i've
divided things up into sections
sections a b c d e and f
and uh you know those obviously go with
the different sections of
that are being displayed on the web page
and i'm going in the order in which i'm
expecting them to be displayed
but keep in mind that you know
regardless of the order in which they
appear in the html
and regardless of the names i've given
them i can completely scramble them up
that's no problem uh as long as i'm
placing them with
grid layout if i'm using float or
flexbox uh it gets
messier flexbox you can actually reorder
elements so you know i think you could
but you could probably put these in
different orders with flexbox
but with float you would pretty much be
stuck with the order in which you've
created them
and then also you know not only can i
change the
uh the placement of the different
elements
i can create other types of grids so
here what i'm showing on the right side
is
hey maybe if i had this being displayed
on a cell phone i would want a
single column instead of three columns
and two rows so you know there's a lot
of flexibility
just by playing around with the grid
okay so let's take a look at the actual
css
so to start off with you can see that
if you look carefully in the image on
the right the screenshot on the right
you can see that
the actual sections have a white
background
and that surrounding them is like this
light gray background so i'm gonna go
ahead and set the body color to
uh f7 f7 f7 so remember those are
hexadecimal digits
uh the first f7 is for red the second f7
is for green and the third f7 is for
blue
and because the amount of red green and
blue is the same um
we've got a shade of gray and we're
going to see that the entire
washington post is designed around
different shades of gray so you
you know anytime you see those pears
repeated those pairs of hexadecimal
digits repeat it that's gray
different shades but all gray and in
addition i've got the font family to set
to sans-serif
i didn't try and figure out what fonts
they were using i just
knew that they were using sansa or font
and again we'll talk about fonts another
lecture
so everything that we're seeing here
this is inside of a div called lower
section
which represents this bottom section of
the washington post
which we're trying to reproduce here and
you can see that i've
said that everything in the lower
section is going to be laid out with a
grid
and i've had the column set to 1fr 1fr1
i'm not setting the rows which defaults
to auto which means that the rows will
increase or decrease in size based on
the elements that i placed inside of
them
okay so you may recall that fr stands
for fractional
and so what one f r one f r one f r
means is that we've got
three columns and the space
available from the web browser will be
evenly divided among those three columns
so whether we've got a you know
relatively
modestly with a web browser window or we
have a really wide web browser window
you know we've still got those three
columns and things will expand or
contract out as necessary
you may notice that also that the the
images on the right are actually wider
and taller than the images on the left
and so this is something we're actually
going to account have to account for
if the images were fixed size but the
columns were able to increase or
decrease in width
we get some odd effects and we don't
want that to happen so we do need to
get those images to widen out as the the
web browser window increases and the frs
increase the space of each of the
columns
okay so uh after we've set up the
the overall body i'm getting that
background color set we've set
everything to san serif
and we set up our columns the next thing
we're going to do is we're going to look
at each of these individual sections
so as section a section b section c and
all the way up to section f
and here are the style
properties i'm setting for each of those
sections i'm setting
padding and margin so keep in mind that
the padding is a space between
the internal elements and that border
and the margin is the space
outside of the border so i need to
control both of those
if i don't set any padding the border is
going to be crammed
right up against each of the text items
there and if i don't
control the margin all my elements will
be
right up against each other and then
i've got a number of different colors as
i mentioned we've already talked about
the web page background being that light
colored gray
and the sections themselves have a white
background it turns out that there are
several other colors
that the washington post is using and i
actually went in with
photoshop with their little eyedropper
tool and so i am
using their exact colors here uh if you
look carefully you can see that the top
left and right of each of these sections
is looks a little bit like maybe there's
a slight edge or maybe a little 3d look
there
and that's because the background color
the section
and the background color of the webpage
is actually different from the
background color of the border so there
is a slight difference there
and then if you look really carefully
you can see that the bottom
border is actually a little bit thicker
so
we do need to get those down and it
turns out that bottom border is a
slightly different color
and we'll take a look at how i set that
up a little bit later and then you'll
also notice that there are
lines separating each of the individual
items so
well i guess this is the downside of
using lorem ipsum i have no idea how to
pronounce this but
if you look at the pretium magna and
then there's a line underneath it
and then there's the eu in period diet
and then there's a line underneath it
and so on so that line actually turns
out to be a different color as well
now if you look at all these different
colors i've got we've got the f7 f7 f7
we've got white which is you know if we
actually want to specify that with
uh with actual hexadecimal numbers that
would be ffff
turn all the red all the green all the
blue to maximum
and then you have ea aea d8 d5 d5 d5 and
so remember what i said a little bit
earlier
uh when you see these repeated
hexadecimal digits that means the amount
of red green and blue
is exactly the same and so what you're
really doing is you're not
trying to mix the colors you're actually
just increasing or decreasing the
intensity and so these are creating
different shades of gray
okay so the background color of these uh
sections is white
um and then we've got our borders here
so
don't forget we need to set that border
style to solid if you don't set the
border style you set the border width
and the border color
and you don't set a border style you get
nothing all right so let's take a closer
look at these borders
uh remember there are several different
ways we can specify the border
uh we can explicitly say border border
with left border with right border
with top border with bottom um we can
set
border width for all of them with a
single value we can put two values one
for top and bottom one for left and
right
or we can specify four and you can see
that's what we're actually doing here so
remember
top right bottom left so we've got one
pixel one pixel and then as i said that
if you look at that bottom border it's
actually a little bit
thicker that's actually two pixels
instead of one pixel
and then the same thing happens on these
colors so i specify four colors
uh the three colors that are the same
are the top right and left and then the
bottom is actually
um quite a bit darker okay also
uh if you look carefully you'll notice
that there's a slight
curve on the corner there this is
determined by the border radius here i
set three different border radiuses
and the first one is no radius at all
and you get that square corner and then
i've
used the border radius 5 pixels which is
what i'm using
and then i have one set to 15 pixels
just to kind of emphasize what that
border radius does if you're still not
seeing it
here they are highlighted look in that
lower left hand corner and you can see
uh you can see how that all works um
and you may also hear to be able to hear
maddie uh drink it from her water dish
she's
she's actually been wandering around the
living room where i'm recording this
kind of looking at me like let's play i
really want to play why are you talking
to that
that you know why have you been spending
all this time working on the computer
getting these graphics right and now
you're talking at that thing
you should be paying attention to me i'm
super cute
all right um and then here i go ahead
and place all the elements down in the
individual grid elements this is super
straightforward you know just
hey that one goes in column one row one
that one goes in column two row one and
so on
very straightforward okay so now we're
going to take a look at the individual
sections
uh there are a few key points here so
you can see
this is one of the sections it has a
number of different components first of
all there's a
h3 which is providing the section
heading
which in this case is lorem and i
actually don't have an h1 or an h2 here
but
my assumption was that certainly you
would want an h1
for the main heading on the top of the
entire web page the washington post and
it's likely that
there might be some other more important
headings up top which you might want to
use in h2 for so
i sort of assumed at this point we're
relatively getting into the middle of
the
heading important so i went ahead and
used h3s4
for these section headings um and you'll
notice here
down at the bottom left i say no styling
i actually did not
end up doing any stein with the h3
either with the h3s themselves or with
this class
section heading it looked right so i
just went ahead and left it
it has the default size
default weight and default mark top and
bottom margin i didn't do anything at
all with it
okay and then we have the image so this
is an image
it's a photograph of the hms victory
which was uh
admiral nelson's flagship at the battle
of trafalgar
and i went ahead and gave us a class
and you'll notice that almost everything
i've been doing
here in this part is marked as a class
the individual sections have ids because
i want to place those
in specific locations but as far as the
images and the headings go
and the sections go those are all marked
as classes not ids because
they have the same characteristics i'm
going to use on all of them so remember
use
id if you've got a specific item that
you want a
very specific set of rules for uh in
this case placement on a grid
you know it seems pretty clear we would
not want to place several items on the
grid in the same location that would
make sense so those use ids but
everything else uses a class because
i'm going to use common styling on all
the different elements you can also use
type selectors i
there are a few places i use type
selectors okay so in this case
i'm giving this image a class a section
image
and i'm going to go ahead and set the
style the width style to 100 percent and
so what this is going to do is
this is going to increase the size of
the
image width to however much space is
available to it
by whatever element it's contained
within and the reason why i set the
width to 100 percent is remember
we're setting the columns to one fr
each and as the web page widens the fr
is increasing width and so
i want these images to increase or
decrease in size depending on
how wide the column they're placed
within is and so by setting
the image width to 100 percent
if that column gets wide the image gets
wide
and since i'm not saying a height the
height and width will
increase proportionally to the proper
proportions based on the original image
okay and then i've got a number of sub
sections these are divs
and they may include multiple elements
so
in this first one you can see i've got
that word up on top
analysis followed by the actual title
there
and so this is actually coming from the
original washington post some of their
little topics down here are just marked
with the name of the topic but some of
them are marked as analysis some of them
are marked as review and some of them
are marked as perspective
and we use a slightly smaller font which
we'll get to in a minute
uh and they appear directly above the
name of the title
and so i combined all this into a single
div
and so you can see this div contains a
secondary div with that analysis word on
there and then it also has an h4
and the next one also has that analysis
the little div on top of it with an h4
and the last one
just has the div itself and so
you can see what i've done here is the
entire div the outer div the
subsection title div which includes
analysis as well as the tile of the
article
that has a 10 pixel margin and 10 pixel
padding
and so that in 10 pixel margin and
padding encloses both the
word analysis as well as whatever's
underneath it so this is not
10 pixels between analysis and what
uh and pretium magna it's
10 pixels outside of analysis and
pratium
all right so you'll notice that um there
are lines between each of the elements
here
and so i need to write a rule that's
going to take care of that and so i've
gone ahead and done that by setting the
border bottom to one pixel solid and
then that d5 d5 d5
again that's a that's a shade of gray
now i only want them to go below the
first two
elements i don't want it to go below the
last element
and so the way i'm going to do this is
i'm going to override the behavior on
the last element by using this
pseudo class last child and so because
that last element
the ut ante metas
is the last subsection title
it's the last child of its parent
i'm going to override the border bottom
and set it to 0 pixel so
all of the elements are going to have a
bottom border except for the last child
that will not have a bottom border and
so that's how i'm going to go ahead and
create the lines between each of the
elements
but not below the last element
okay and then finally here's how i
actually set the
font size and weight for uh
each of the uh analysis
as well as the uh the wording below the
word analysis
and um this one uses analysis in in
both the first two elements there are
other places where i use different
i use the perspective and the review
just as the original washington post
does just not in this particular example
here
and so you can see i set the h4
which is the main text for each of these
subsection titles i've set it to
margin 0 padding 0 and font size 12
points so this is actually worth
mentioning
so a lot of the different elements on
the web page
do have preset margin particularly top
and bottom margin
all the headings have preset top and
bottom margin
and you may want to get rid of that and
so that's what i'm doing here i'm
explicitly saying
yeah i know that there's a margin
already set for the h
force but let's not use that margin i
want to get rid of that margin
this is semantically an h4 so i want to
leave it marked as an h4 but i want to
override
the the box behavior which includes some
margin padding and border there's no
preset border but i do want to get rid
of the margin and padding i'm going to
go ahead and set to 0 pixels
particularly because i want that word
analysis to be right up against it
just as it is in the washington post
example so i'm going to go ahead and get
rid of that
i'm going to set the font size to 12
point and turns out the default behavior
on the h4 is going to go ahead and set
it to bold
so i get the look that i'm looking for
and then the subsection
type that's the analysis or perspective
or review
that's just a div and so i do need to
provide uh
whatever styling i want on it and so i'm
going to go ahead and set the font size
to nine point and i'm going to set the
font weight to bold
so that's our little reproduction of the
bottom section of the washington post
um you know again uh
hopefully the main the number one
takeaway i want you guys to get from
this
is hey i can do this like this is a
professional web page
i can make a web page that looks every
bit as good as this professional web
page does
you know and with the techniques we've
shown you it's really not that hard
it's going to take you some time to do
the analysis it's going to take you some
time to do some tweaking to get the
sizes right the spacing's the way you
want
but you could definitely reproduce these
things
and assuming you have the artistic
skills which i don't necessarily have
but
if you have the artistic and graphic
design skills you know you can go ahead
and come up with one of these on your
own and you can go ahead
and turn your vision into reality using
the cascading style sheets we've been
teaching you
all right i'll talk to you guys soon